et à laisser les processeurs
depuis la mi mai les clients de fumer
l'achète leur chapeau afrique spurs
le couple de chapellerie a passé trois
ans à montréal en plein centre ville
l'année passée on se dit que vu qu'on se
voyait à long terme aller en région mais
le pour qu attaquer tout de suite à
court terme en région dans cinq mois
les deux entrepreneurs ont complètement
transformé un anti reste au bas d'un peu
fou à quelques pas de sens à l'est de la
ville mais des jeux le jeu trouve que en
2e on est moins perdus dans la masse
puis il ya tellement de gens passionnés
en région ils ont aussi installé un coin
buvette avec deux terrasses qui vient
est pas pressé par le temps de prendre
un café ou un verre entente asseoir
prendre prendre le temps de bien choisir
son chapeau puis on veut que ça soit un
tour l'objectif que les clients visitent
la boutique au moins une fois choquante
on moule de teintes pour avoir leurs
mesures exactes et bien collé sur après
ce qu'ils veulent peuvent commander en
ligne les chapeaux qui se vendent entre
200 et 1000 dollars la clientèle qu'on a
développé à montréal pendant trois ans
et toi qu'est ce qu'on s'attendait cette
même pas des fois du monde de montréal
puis c'est monsieur madame tout le monde
qui apprécie les belles choses qui
veulent se payer de la qualité qui
sous-tend de partout de ces gens là sont
pas juste en ville sur le bernois
le déménagement a permis d'agrandir la
boutique mais aussi l'atelier ce qui
offre la possibilité d'augmenter la
production
oui on est des artistes mais aussi les
entrepreneurs donc on veut que ça
fonctionne qu ici on joue ça fonctionne
il faut offrir des prix compétitifs
mais pour ce faire la chaîne ou 6 x 4 de
produire plus en masse mais tout allait
vraiment l'espace pour les machines mais
aussi pour
tall et comme fou
[Musique]
les propriétaires de fumer il compte
d'ailleurs approché de petites chaînes
de magasins et boutiques indépendantes
pour vendre des collections plus
abordable au lierse et c'est marie
claude marin radio-canada et à meyrueis
la garder
[Musique]